ChatGPT你們都讓我聊我這真的各種私信都快瘀了那咱就聊聊唄我就圖省事啊咱就直接問問ChatGPT能不能幫我寫一個視頻大綱你看1234567就列出來了你詳細說一說第二部分你看又1234告訴我你來幫我寫一段腳本
哎呀媽呀，我連稿都不用寫了，你看看他這稿吧，你也不能深究我要是按他這個講，估計沒兩期我這粉就該掉光了不過啊，咱先刨開他這個內容質量不熟你就光看他這個文字能力你問他什麼都能跟你對答如流，還說的有模有樣的反正是把我給震撼到了
又是拿美國的醫學牌照又是參加司法考試又能寫小說編代碼查資料就感覺只要能用文字表達的事他全都能幹你說這玩意兒他怎麼突然就橫空出事了之前也有聊天機器人怎麼就感覺他就要顛覆世界了讓資本圈好傢伙那個興奮他又有什麼問題呢巨頭們又如何應對他到底會讓誰失業呢
小莉雖然不是什麼人工智能方面的專家不過今天呢咱們就一起把這些碎片的信息都給串起來一起來聊一聊關於ChatGPT你需要知道的那些事
這個聊天機器人咱們得追溯到1950年那時候號稱計算機科學之父人工智能之父的艾倫·圖靈發表了一篇具有畫時代意義的論文提出了一個很有哲理的叫做模仿遊戲也就說咱們大名鼎鼎的那個圖靈測試就是說當你在不面對面的時候跟人家文字聊天你能不能準確的判斷出來對方是一個人還是個機器人如果你要是很難分辨出來呢那就一定程度上可以說這個機器它是智能的
你看這圖靈測試是不是又簡單又易懂又具體而且還挺有意思的所以就吸引了很多計算機方面的科學家來向它發起衝擊不過最開始的時候都是一些非常簡單的指令它就是通過一些語言技巧就是小聰明來盡量讓你感覺到你好像是在跟一個人對話就比如說1966年的時候MIT實驗室裡就發明出來一個聊天機器人叫Eliza
這開發者就很聰明他給Alyssa的設定是個心理治療師你看這種諮詢師一般不都是少說話多傾聽嗎所以他就可以問人家說你有沒有什麼想法人家不拉不拉說一大通然後他又問說你最近休息的怎麼樣人家又不拉不拉說一大通他少說就少錯嘛所以就真的讓人誤以為他在傾聽然後跟你溝通
其實它背後就是一些非常簡單的if 什麼什麼then 什麼什麼的代碼比如說他一看到說mother 媽媽這個詞的時候他就會跟你說跟我說說你的家庭就類似這種的關鍵詞大概有兩百來個然後到了30年之後的1995年Eliza又出來了一個後輩叫Alice他就進化的已經很強大了雖然跟ChatGPT還沒法比但就很日常那些對話他已經都可以應付了不過本質上不管是這個Eliza還是Alice他們的原理都是基於一個叫做pattern matching就是模式匹配
聽到一個關鍵詞他就會調取一個已經預設好的預案就比如說他聽見你好你就問人說吃了嗎他聽見媽媽他就說跟我說你的家庭類似這種其實即使是在現在一些購物網站銀行什麼的機器人他基於的還是這種pattern matching的模式就比如說你跟他聊天你一說到退貨他就給你發個退貨流程或者你一說ATM他就給你發個附近ATM的地圖這種匹配模式他雖然稱不上是非常的智能但確確實實減少了很多那種大量人力機械性的重複回答
但咱就從智能的角度講，你說這種限定規則的機器人，就算你的規則寫的再複雜、預設再多，也不可能窮盡所有的答案，它更不可能去創造新的答案。所以你要真的想通過圖靈測試，想要變成真正的智能，單憑這種模式匹配是不可能實現的。於是就出現了語言學習裡面一個新的流派，這個也是人工智能裡面非常重要的一部分，就是機器學習。
顧名思義，他的基本理念就是讓機器去學習。就是說我不給你人為規定一些規則和回答了，就給你一大堆現成的例子，讓你自己去學習找規律。聽著是不是就感覺厲害多了，也非常符合我們對學習這個邏輯的認知。基於這個理念，2001年就有了一個叫做Smarter Child,更聰明的小孩，這麼個機器人，就活出圈了。
那為什麼火呢？首先他用了一些機器學習裡面當時比較先進的模型來讓聊天變得更自然。而且2000年那會兒不是興起了一大批聊天軟件嗎？AOL、Windows、Yahoo。那個Smart Child就把這些平臺橫掃了一遍，就讓全世界好幾億人都可以跟他對話。不管你問他什麼，你甭管他答的怎麼樣，總能跟你聊著兩句，可以算是Chad GPT的大前輩了。你說這麼好玩的東西立馬就風靡全球，吸引了超過3000萬的用戶跟他對話聊天。他每天光接收的信息就要超過10億條，被各種人撩騷。
直到2007年的時候他被一家巨頭公司給收購了你猜是誰就是微軟
你可以看出來，微軟在那麼早的時候就已經開始基於這個領域了。哇，這個更聰明小孩雖然已經很能聊了，但是離通過圖靈測試還有很長的距離。就你跟他聊兩句就知道，那就是個機器。好，咱們繼續進步。到了2010年的時候，機器學習裡邊的一個領域開始閃光了，叫做人工神經網絡，Artificial Neural Network。
你看我們人的大腦其實是靠超過100億個神經元通過網狀鏈接來判斷和傳遞信息的。雖然每個神經元都很簡單，但是它們組合起來就可以判斷非常複雜的信息。
所以這個人工神經網絡其實就是想模擬人腦的這種形式輸入信息之後就會經過若干個隱藏神經節點的判斷就跟神經元似的然後給你輸出結果其實這個神經網絡的思想早就有了甚至可以追溯到1960年代但是它需要兩樣東西做支撐大量的數據和強大的算力而這些在之前都是不具備的所以這個神經網絡的事就是紙上談兵到了2010年代那不互聯網時代了嗎數據肯定是有了
算力也是持續指數級別的提升，才讓神經網絡這個開始能應用起來。人們就發現，這個模式真的特別適合解決人們一看就知道，就憑直覺的那種事。就比如說你看到一張臉，你就能迅速知道他是誰，當然劉強東除外。我這是臉盲，我根本不知道他漂不漂亮。
你想之前要是讓電腦判斷出這個人是誰那簡直太難了但是你用這個神經網絡機器學習就能慢慢摸索出規律現在它的應用已經非常廣了不光人臉識別像聲音識別自動駕駛包括前幾年夏威夷打開科傑那個AlphaGo都是用這招練出來的
所以說，這個神經網絡在剛才我們說的那些領域都可以大展宏圖，但回到文字領域，它發展就不太順。為什麼呢？因為這個機器學習一般都是用一種叫做循環神經網絡，就是RNN來處理文字的。它主要的方式就是按順序一個詞一個詞看，一個詞一個詞處理。問題就是它沒法同時進行大量的學習，而且句子也不能太長，要不然你學到後面的時候前面都忘了。
直到2017年的時候谷歌出了一篇論文提出來了一個新的學習框架叫做Transformer
有了這個Transformer,機器在文字學習方面，那就像打通了人多二脈。現在很多自然語言處理模型，其實都是建立在它的基礎架構之上的。谷歌那個BERT裡頭的T,包括ChatGPT裡頭的T,都是指這個Transformer。
好，你看，現在技術方面已經有非常強的突破，萬事俱備，那不就差人和錢了嗎？是時候是ChatGPT登場了。就在2015年，包括馬斯克、彼得·蒂爾在內幾個大佬一起註資了10億美金，成立了一家非盈利組織叫OpenAI,也就是ChatGPT的母公司，來進行AI方面的研究。
你看他非盈利嘛，就是說我不是為了賺錢，我純粹是為了推動這項技術的發展。所以他的研究成果包括專利都是對外公開的。你看這個投資人裡，咱們是不是又聽到了大家都非常熟悉的馬斯克。實際上他逐漸發現他的特斯拉在AI方面也需要大量的投入研究，搞自動駕駛什麼的。所以就為了避免特斯拉跟OpenAI這兩家公司的利益衝突，他就在2018年，也就是OpenAI成立的第三年，退出了董事會，就白白不玩了。所以現在這個OpenAI其實跟馬斯克已經關係不搭了。
而OpenAI這些大牛們也確實很厲害。2017年穀歌不是推出了那個Transformer嗎？他們就立馬在這個基礎上研究學習。18年發表了一篇論文，介紹了一個新的語言學習模型，叫做Generative Pre-trained Transformer,就是GPT。之前的語言學習模型，它基本都是需要人去監督，或者人為給它設定一些標籤，但那個GPT就基本不怎麼需要了。你就把一堆數據放進去，它就誇誇一頓學就給學明白了，大概就這個意思。
OpenAI就在2018年6月推出了第一代GPT,接著在2019年11月又增加了訓練的數據量，推出了GPT-2。這種機器學習主要就拼兩件事，一個是模型，一個是參數量。模型就是你決定了機器怎麼學。同樣的數據，我進去，我學的比誰都快，比誰都好，那你就厲害。
而參數量其實需要大量計算，所以說白了就是要砸錢。就算是模型再好，也得靠砸錢去訓練和驗證，這兩者缺一不可。OpenAI團隊對我這個模型很有信心，下一步不就缺錢了嗎？而你每進步一點都可能需要上升一個數量級的數據去支撐，這些都是需要真金白銀去支持的。比如說Google DeepMind研究出來AlphaGo的公司，每年開銷4-5億美元。
最開始OpenAI這邊我們不是說投了10億美元嗎？那根本不夠花呀。注意這時候它還是個非盈利組織。馬斯克也退出了，大腿不在了。之前10億美元情懷不夠了，我上哪再找那麼多情懷去。所以迫於資金壓力，OpenAI就在2019年從非盈利組織轉型了。
但是它沒有直接變成一個盈利組織，還是得要點情懷。而是變成了一個叫做收益封頂的盈利組織。它什麼意思呢？就是說任何投資人的投資回報都不能超過100倍。超過100倍的部分，投資人就拿不到回報了，就都歸OpenAI自己了。但是我就好奇，你說我要是投資回報快到100倍了，我就撤出來然後重新投，那不又能拿100倍了嗎？
反正不管怎麼說OpenAI變成了一家盈利組織也就是說你投資它是可以拿到回報了這時候微軟就立刻衝了過來注資10億美元
這筆投資對雙方肯定都是雙贏的。OpenAI這邊一是拿到了錢，二是微軟也給它建了一個全球第五的超級計算機，大大提升了它訓練效率。微軟也得到了OpenAI的技術和團隊。當然這樣的話，OpenAI的研究成果也就別想再公開了。你說微軟能投的是情懷嗎？OpenAI得到了超能力和算力支持，就準備開始大力出奇蹟。它之前那個一代的時候只有1.2億個參數。
到了GPT-2是15億個而這回半年之後又推出了GPT-3直接上升了100倍變成了1750億個效果果然就真的非常好已經有那麼點現在這個ChatGPT的意思了就你問他點什麼他都能給你打出來當時在業內就已經掀起了一波轟動不過這個純機器訓練出來的GPT-3它有個問題就是它有的時候打得很好有的時候就差那麼點意思而且問題就在於你不管再怎麼加大參數量它的提升和改善都非常有限
這個呢就因為他在訓練的時候沒有一個非常好的反饋機制就是沒有人告訴他你答成什麼樣是對的答成什麼樣是不好的你看啊我要是訓練下棋那我就想贏對吧贏了就是好的那我就訓練上自己贏但是你說聊天那就很難判斷了我怎麼知道我聊的是好的還是不好的我就只能在那乾學
所以為瞭解決這個問題，OpenAI就在訓練的時候加入了一個人工反饋的機制。就是你跟我聊天，我告訴你，你聊的是好還是不好。專業術語就叫人工反饋的強化學習。所以你用拆GPT的時候，你就感覺他有時候特頻特能說，其實這都是因為訓練他的人就喜歡他這麼說。要是訓練他的人是個特別幽默的人，那估計拆GPT就整天給你講段子了。
反正就是加入了這個人工反饋的強化學習之後不管是訓練的效率還是效果都得到了大大的提升在2022年3月就推出了GPT 3.5之後又對對話進行了優化在2022年11月就推出了ChatGPT
它其實就是一個非常極其簡單粗糙的聊天見面。但是你問它什麼，人家都問給你巴拉巴回答一通。感覺說的還很有道理。當然這裡邊會有一些問題，這我們之後再說。但是你就粗略的一看，它真的是什麼都能聊。而且語言表達上真的就說的跟那麼回事似的。經歷了半個世紀，拆GPT這次肯定是可以輕輕鬆鬆就通過圖靈測試了。是不是挺厲害的。這就不禁讓我想到了，復塗牛牛的海外版。
部圖有70%多的人都是搞產品跟研發的。就是想靠科技創新，讓投資交易更簡單。一個賬戶就可以搞定美股、港股、澳股、西亞富股、A股通、基金、外匯、期貨、債券佈局全球。
MOMO也給小林粉絲準備了專屬福利。開戶就送一股Under Armour的股票。你要在入金等額一萬港幣，還可以再送一股價值約100美元的Google的股票。最近啊，這個ChatGPT不是火了嗎？你要是想看都帶火了哪些概念股，你就在這直接搜ChatGPT就能看見了，美股港股都有。你看啊，不光是像微軟谷歌這些大家都聽說過的巨頭，
還有一些你之前可能沒聽說過的那種潛力股比如說我要想看看哪個股票的潛力比如說就臺積電吧那這種華爾街分析師的評級、目標價的預測還有這個股票有幾個急急消急的信號默默全都給你整理出來了反正大家平時關心的資金面、技術面、基本面都挺全的
而且它不光是把這些信息都免費給你整理出來，包括這圖啊，可視化，做的都還挺直觀的。包括實時更新的全球AI相關的資訊，甚至都給你翻譯好了。除了ChatGPT,它這裡邊還有叫做概念板塊，你就能看到別的概念股。你看什麼機器人科學啊，物聯網啊，就算你不炒股瞭解一下都挺好的。它們還有毫秒級報價，還有0.0037秒急速下單等等這些能力，你就能看出來真的是想在科技上大力出奇蹟。最近Momo剛在日本也開放了平臺的功能體驗，用戶都說，
感性的朋友可以通過下面鏈接領鼓體驗一下。好，咱們收回拆GPT。反正啊，它就確確實實已經顛覆了大多數人，包括我在內，對聊天機器人的認知。所以在短短的兩個月內，拆GPT的月活就突破了1億人。擴張速度肯定是史上最快，各種數據怎麼吹都不為過。不過說實話，拆GPT它這麼強的顛覆性，它產品本身給人們帶來的震撼已經遠遠超過那些數據了。
直到現在我看他回答問題的時候就關鍵他不是那個一口氣就全給你出來是真就那麼一點一點坑著坑著就跟個人在那跟你說話似的我這人還真起一身雞皮疙瘩不過我估計一年之後大家再看這種應該就見怪不關了好咱們來看看這個Chad GPT他是怎麼做到就你不管在什麼領域問他問題他都能聊的
簡單來說，就類似GPT這種大型的語言模型，它本質上就是在那計算下一個詞、下一句話該出現什麼，就是個概率問題。就比如說它說到了我很，要往下接，那數據庫裡那麼多詞可以是我很開心、我很健康、我很著急、我很餓等等。但是你要有個上下文，比如上面說今天天氣不錯，那它可能就計算出來說大概率就是我很開心。其實它的每個回答每個詞都是這麼簡單粗暴靠前文的相關性來計算出來的。
當他學習內容足夠多，就上千億的參數和文字，通過這些複雜模型找規律之後，他自己就形成了一個非常龐大的神經網絡。就是你完全不需要告訴他什麼叫編程，什麼是視頻腳本，他自己看多了，他就知道了編程就是這麼寫代碼，視頻腳本就該長這樣。所以我讓他幫我寫一個拆GPT的視頻腳本，他就從他總結出來的那個相關興趣一個詞一個詞往外蹦就完了。你看他本質上還是一個語言模型，就是在學別人說話。
那他知道他自己說的是什麼意思嗎？至少目前這個ChatGP的版本他還完全不懂。他就像是個記憶力特別好，但是什麼都不太懂的小孩在那學大人說話。但讓我們以為他好像什麼都懂了。這也是為什麼，你看他說的那個話真的都已經非常完美，非常像人類了。但是呢，還經常會犯一些邏輯性的錯誤，就是我們看著覺得非常弱智，就加減成熟這種錯誤。就是因為他其實是一個語言模型。目前來講，相對於他講的對不對，他更在意的是我說的像不像那麼回事。
實際上GPT也經常會出現大量編造答案的情況也就是說他本來都不知道他在說什麼但他就是在那給你硬扯也包括很多道德倫理上的問題比如說你問他怎麼看人類他就跟你說人類是裂道的自私的是最爛的生物就應該徹底被消滅他真的是這麼想的嗎那他肯定也不知道自己在那說什麼也不知道從哪學來的
不過這些胡說八道什麼的問題都是現在這個版本的拆GPT的問題雖然現在它可能就是簡單的模仿但是當你模仿的越來越像越來越高級就不99.9%的情況你都能回答正確的時候那它到底是真的理解了還是純粹在那模仿是不是就其實意義也不大了這個其實也是圖靈早在圖靈測試那篇論文裡面就討論過的一個問題就是與其我們問說機器能像人類一樣思考嗎倒不如問說機器能做人類做的事嗎有點深度了
其實我覺得ChatGPT它重大的一個突破就是極大的提升了人類和機器之間溝通的效率人類之間溝通信息的方式主要是文字那電腦呢它是用代碼那之前呢就人類就簽就是電腦嘛什麼事我都得先學編程然後想好了把它編成一個電腦能理解的語言然後讓它執行包括搜索我們也是先把自己的問題換成幾個關鍵詞然後去搜
但有了這些語言模型之後呢，它就變了。電腦可以慢慢理解人了。我呢就可以直接跟他說人話，然後他自己去翻譯自己去執行。大家都覺得ChatGPT很神奇哈，你問他什麼他都知道。但其實它的神奇之處並不在於說他能去執行這些任務，更主要的是他能非常準確的理解你的問題。然後呢結合語境從他那龐大的數據庫裡面提煉出來最恰當的信息，換成人話再告訴你。他這個溝通的環節其實是裡面最神奇的。
有了一個這麼強大的接口，那很多東西我們就可以更輕鬆的交給機器去做。那做事的效率就大大提高了嘛。你就想像啊，假設我們能把它跟一個語言識別系統，比如說像Siri這種連起來，讓它可以跟你自由對話。然後你要再能接上一些專業的分析接口，比如什麼AI的股票分析啊，編程啊，計算啊，什麼機器人。然後再接上一個視覺生成的部分。好傢伙，那咱真的每個人就能像電影裡那鋼鐵俠跟他助手似的。
比如你跟他說你幫我算一下莫比烏斯環那什麼什麼﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗﹗
1月份就宣佈給OpenAI再注資100億美元，估值達到了290億美元。而且這回微軟跟OpenAI簽的這個deal還挺有意思的。就是微軟投完這100億美元之後，OpenAI的利潤裡邊75%得先分給微軟，直到把這100億回本。就是微軟得先保證我投進去的錢能收回來。然後微軟持有OpenAI49%的股權。
可能還有個100倍投資回報的上限。大概就是這麼一個奇特的Deo。這個Deo達成之後，接下來2月7號，微軟就舉辦了發布會，宣佈要把ChatGPT融入到自己的搜索引擎定裡。微軟就把它叫做Copilot for the Web,大概就是個網絡助手吧。其實ChatGPT有一個問題，就是它訓練的那些數據只截止到2021年，
也就是說最近發生的事他都不知道。那微軟把它跟病這麼一結合，你看邏輯類的我可以用chatGPT,如果需要信息或者新聞我拿病這麼一搜，這不就強強聯合了嗎？你比如說我要是問chatGPT,你知道小林說嗎？他就只能說他不知道。
那我要是問病呢？他就說，小林說是一個又有趣又有用的內容創作者，是很多要追求自己夢想的人的好榜樣。說的我都有點不好意思了，所以這夥是有他道理的。而且微軟還很陰險，他這個聊天功能必須用他自己家的愛紙瀏覽器才能用。不得不說，這一波的營銷和造勢我給滿分。
面對這一波鋪天蓋地的宣傳，這時候最慌的就是谷歌了。為什麼呢？因為拆GPT很可能會撼動他們最大的一塊蛋糕，就是搜索。你想啊，那我要問拆GPT,他都能組織好語言告訴我，那我要想搜東西的時候，我就不用再去查看了自己挨個兒看了，我就直接問拆GPT就行了，對吧？那就沒人再用搜索引擎了，那你說谷歌他能不慌嗎？
你要知道，它現在佔有全球搜索市場的份額是93%,那是妥妥的壟斷。微軟那個病呢，雖然排在第二，但只有3%。搜索業務帶來的廣告收入能佔到谷歌總收入60%。你說大家本來都做得好好的，突然橫空跳出來個什麼什麼屁屁。
其實一直以來谷歌在人工智能領域都是領先的，你想那個Transformer不就他搞出來的嗎？他其實一直也在內測一個機器人，叫Bert,跟ChessGPT很像，只不過沒有花大量的精力去訓練他。他其實還有另外一個機器人，更厲害叫Lambda,完全就是基於人類正常的對話，所以他甚至還會開玩笑或者表達自己的情感，就完全不是說光你問他才是回答這麼簡單。
就因為他說話確實是太自然了甚至於都騙過了當時在谷歌內部一個開發測試的員工相信Lambda已經具備了自己的意識就差不多像個七八歲的小孩
所以谷歌其實在聊天機器人這塊一直都是很強的但是他的立場跟微軟就完全不一樣了你想谷歌本來就是搜索領域的王者他吃飽了撐著非非搞個機器人然後把自己的謠遣術給砍了嗎那不到萬不得已肯定不會的所以這也是為什麼我估計他那個Lambda更專注於對話和聊天而不是像ChatGPT這種就什麼問題都能回答
而且呢，他一直不把這些AI機器人放出來，也是擔心自己的名譽風險。谷歌它畢竟是搜索的嘛，要的就是要準確嚴謹。你說你要是推出來個還沒訓練好的胡八八道的機器人，那多不像話。
另一方面，這麼大規模的訓練是非常需要算力和燒錢的。每個問題消耗的能源，大概是現在谷歌搜索的10到100倍。你像CHAT GPT這種，現在每天就要花掉100萬美元來運行。所以你看得出來，微軟這波先發優勢也是確實非常有道理的。它不光投對了公司，而且真的是下得了狠手去砸錢。面對微軟這邊強大的輿論壓力，加上媒體鋪天蓋地的報導，谷歌是真的坐不住了。
XGPC剛上線不久谷歌內部就發布了一個叫做紅色預警Code Red這是我們生死存亡的關鍵時刻了我們得集中全公司的力量到AI這個賽道上了因為這個東西關鍵它就是得快它有多快呢快到谷歌把自己的腰給扭掉了
咱剛剛不是說微軟的發佈會是2月7號嗎？說把ChatGPT融入到他的搜索引擎裡了。谷歌這邊急忙2月8號就舉辦了發佈會，發佈了自己的對話服務，叫Bird。這個就是基於他們剛剛那個對話機器人Lambda開發的。你就看看谷歌發佈會之後，微軟和谷歌這兩個公司的股價，你就知道谷歌這發佈會到底有多慘。
我們錯過了電話。
後來好不容易進入到正題開始介紹這個Bird了也就說了幾分鐘就完了而且谷歌發布會的時候同時還發布了一個介紹Bird的視頻要命的是這個視頻裡頭Bird的回答還出現了事實性的錯誤其實說實在的現在這種聊天機器人他出現一點事實性的錯誤大家也是可以理解的但是你廣告片上的答案都沒查清楚手機還忘帶瞭然後雷聲大雨點小一帶而過肉眼可見能看到谷歌的倉促和慌亂這個才是市場擔心的
雖然拆GPT風光無限﹐可大家都知道Google是AI領域的強者﹐所以就算你短時間內沒怎麼吭聲﹐估計外部人也知道你不好惹﹐你估計是在那憋大招﹐你看它發布那個紅色預警﹐其實有個原因可能就是讓外部知道﹐說我很重視這個事﹐你們先別著急賣股票﹐所以你看發布會之前谷歌的股價﹐跟微軟比也並不差﹐可是非得著急忙慌搞了這麼一出﹐那不就有點露怯了﹐所以谷歌的市值一下蒸發了一千億美元﹐
相比之下，微軟那邊就穩多了。你看微軟的CEO,OpenAI的CEO,全都出來親自講解。將近一個小時的發布會，都在著重講這個AI聊天的功能。還加上各種演示，很明顯就是做了充分的準備。這AI戰爭剛一打響，谷歌這邊先是被拆GPT搞了個措手不及。然後自己一慌，又來了個D級失誤。可以說這第一仗算是慘敗。但這個畢竟也只是第一仗，谷歌畢竟也還是谷歌。後面怎麼樣呢？我們就事不宜待了。
當然，這場AI戰爭也絕不僅限於這兩家公司。像Meta、百度、騰訊、阿里也都搶著入局。但凡和生成式AI沾邊的股票都開始狂漲。像英偉達、AMD這種提供算力基礎的硬件廠商也跟著沾光。其實，像AI聊天、AI作畫、AI編程這些生成式AI,在前兩年就已經迎來了井噴式的發展。在這個方向，過去幾年的融資額從2021-2022年就已經開始起飛了，每年都是十多億美元。
但2023年一開年微軟啪就先砸進去了100個億資本已經盡其所能全都湧到這個賽道了好那這個東西發展的這麼快它會不會導致很多人失業呢它又會導致誰失業呢會不會導致你失業呢就這種技術革新它永遠都是一把雙刃劍它可能會創造出來更多的工作就失業率也不一定降總體的GDP八成還會上升但是短期內它肯定會導致一部分人失業
我就在想，你說咱們怎麼能盡可能的不讓自己失業，甚至說能夠利用這個AI工具來提高自己的生產力呢？我個人的總結，就是咱們得盡量避免那種套路性的工作。就以前電腦剛出來的時候，可能解決的是一些人類的重複性工作，就我每天都在那不停的不停的重複一件事，你搞個電腦for loop,就給解決了。
那現在就不光是那種重複性工作了就連套路性工作就只要你有套路哪怕你感覺你每天在那創作實際上根本沒動太多腦子就這種事那機器也能分分鐘就給你玩明白了那什麼叫套路性工作呢我給你舉個例子就比如說我讓拆GPT寫一個有關小林的童話故事他就說小林有一隻會說話的貓他打敗了惡龍拯救了公主成了英雄那我告訴他不對小林是個女的你重編他說小林是個女的有一隻會說話的貓打敗了邪惡的女巫成了英雄
所以你看啊，這就是童話故事的套路，它有一隻會說話的動物，打敗了一個東西，成了英雄。雖然這個會說話的貓，它在裡面毫無作用，但這就是童話故事的標配。就類似的，比如有一些特別熟練的工程師，整天閉著眼睛去叭叭叭能寫的代碼，寫手閉著眼睛就能一天寫20條的那封網文，或者公司一些特別基本的財務報告啊，基本的設計，基本的法律建議等等。
你想為什麼這些活我熟練了之後閉著眼睛都能幹？就因為它背後有套路。那現在AI學會這些套路，那你也不用閉著眼睛幹了，AI全都給你包了。注意，我並不是說程序員、會計師、作家、分析師這些人都會被取代，只是說他們工作當中裡邊那些套路性的部分，會慢慢機器就會學會了。所以你要是感覺自己工作當中有一些套路性的成分，那你就得小心了。反正至少你別把那些套路放在網上，這樣AI不就都學去了嗎？
其實不光是事業這塊，就是因為它的顛覆性實在是太強了，我們已經能看到它給現在的社會造成了巨大的衝擊。你就比如說學校教育這塊，它才上線幾個月，現在美國18歲以上的學生裡，都有九成用過ChatGPT幫他寫作業了。
而且它基本上除了體育是不是哪一科都能做？你說我怎麼知道你這作業是不是自己寫的？當然不是說這個東西我們就不能用它幫忙了只是說我們現在的教育體系還沒有準備好讓拆GPT進來這個顛覆性它就好像我們用幾百年好不容易建立了一套比較完善的交通系統結果突然有一天這車全都會飛了飛車嘛這個技術長期來看它肯定是好的但短期呢我們還沒有一套完整的新的體系的時候所有人都滿天亂飛那不就亂套了嗎？那社會的秩序就會被極大的擾亂
所以你看像學校公司一時他也想不好拆GPT怎麼融入到自己現有的體系那就只能一刀切直接先都給禁止包括你說像AI他寫的內容他畫的畫到底算誰創作的版權算誰的對吧這些其實都是很棘手的問題所以說這種生成式AI他之後到底能發展什麼樣其實誰也說不準你想拆GPT團隊他最最開始的時候也沒有什麼特別多的目的就是純粹把數據放進去讓機器去學習弄出來之後才發現原來這麼厲害還能跟搜索連接上
大家其實也都是摸著石頭過河所以你也不知道突然哪天在AI在哪個領域就開竅了我有時候就感覺能見證AI這麼神奇的發展其實還是個挺激動的事潘多拉的磨合也在一點一點被我們打開了